alors moi je suis très très très très
contente parce que j'ai pas vu Daniel
depuis 12 jours non et il rentre ce soir
du Qatar
qui m'a beaucoup manqué il est dans
l'avion et on se retrouve ce soir après
l'émission
c'est pas vrai Daniel revient voilà
exactement
j'ai préparé des pâtes au bouillon
[Rires]
il arrive vers il sera à la maison vers
22h-2h15
tu auras le temps de préparer les pâtes
au bouillon tu veux je peux même te
libérer avant ma chérie non non du tout
elles sont déjà prêtes en fait
c'est un vrai secret ça j'aime bien moi
si j'en ai un c'est les amis c'est les
amis
c'est les amis on va vers toi d'accord
moi je n'ai je n'ai pas de secret je
n'ai pas de secret pas pour ma femme et
sûrement pas pour toi donc je vois pas
pourquoi j'inventerai un faux secret ça
va toi sinon le moment
je suis un peu embrassé ce que je fais
des rêves érotiques avec une personne
autour de la table depuis plusieurs
jours
je pense que c'est un homme un homme
là c'est vrai et toi tu es content
si je devais franchir le pas ce sera
avec lui donc ouais
alors là j'ai un moi j'ai un secret
aussi vas-y c'est que Daniel rentre mais
moi c'est Fatou qui s'en va non
[Rires]
n'oubliez pas cocu un jour cocu toujours
Dany donc ça s'est très bien passé
courir dans le désert
nos vacances là parce que pour mon
anniversaire souvenez-vous il m'a offert
des vacances à Zanzibar pour nos 10 ans
Noël et anniversaire
rattraper je connais par cœur ça je
connais pas
notre ami tu ne connais pas
[Applaudissements]
mon ami c'est vrai que lui ou si c'est
vous ah ah je suis en train
de me fait chier tu as vu je te cache
pas t'éclater que Ben
tout à l'heure ouais
tu m'emmerdes moi j'ai un secret
tu deviens de plus en plus tactile c'est
mon Raymond euh
c'est une belle pub pour la communauté
alors moi j'ai un secret mais j'ai peur
que ça se réalise pas si j'en parle en
fait il y a peu de chance que ça serait
mais si ça va se réaliser j'ai trouvé un
mécène Lionel Stan le directeur général
et en secret là on va on va louer des
box de parking on est en train de
trafiquer des phobies pour louer des
boxes faire qu'avec un bip je vais
reproduire plusieurs bip de parking mais
dans quelle partie en Pologne Boulogne
et Paris et on va louer des box à 150 €
le moins avec Lionel les boxs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi j'ai deux secrets
non aujourd'hui on m'a proposé de jouer
dans une pièce de théâtre
[Applaudissements]
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est quelque
chose pour 2023 qui me qui me plairait
bien parce que j'ai accepté
et mon deuxième secret c'est que dans
les podcasts que je fais on a parlé des
fétichistes des pieds dernièrement et on
m'a demandé moi quel était le membre du
corps que j'aimais vraiment chez les
hommes et je me suis rendu compte qu'en
fait moi c'était les nez donc en fait je
suis nasophile
[Rires]
c'est un secret en fait je me suis je me
suis rendue compte je me suis découverte
[Rires]
avec des garçons cyril a le plus beau
pour moi d'accord
il y a une corrélation entre l'oseille
et la beauté des neiges
et le théâtre
alors moi comme tout le monde a donné
ses allers-retours matrimoniaux au mois
de décembre mon mari ne partira pas en
Italie de tout le mois et c'est moi qui
vais faire des allers-retours avec la
Belgique
[Musique]
faire quoi parce qu'on comprend pas je
conseille que ton mari quand il va en
Italie
[Rires]
il était tranquillement en train de du
coup arrête de bouffer le cul
alors c'est comme lui c'est un bail
professionnel dans la tournée
exactement de comédie surtout que des
cocus
pardon mais dis-moi ton secret
cette année à Noël
[Musique]
tu peux pas dénigrer l'animateur cette
année à Noël attends j'ai accepté
qu'est-ce qu'il y a non mais rien dans
le cul je parle là
merde revenir
[Rires]
crois-moi tu auras plus peur que moi
alors dis-moi ton secret non cette année
j'ai accepté pour la première fois que
mon copain fasse un sapin de Noël dans
l'appart jusque là j'avais toujours
toujours dit non parce que je trouvais
alors là je vais me faire insulter par
tous les gars de France je trouve que
deux gays avec un sapin dans un appart
c'était grotesque pas parce que pour moi
c'est un truc de famille il faut des
enfants de mecs de 50 ans avec leur
sapin dans un appartement
c'est une fête pour les enfants de Gai
de 50 ans avec leur sapin dans leur
appart
c'était mon avis je vous le donne je le
partage avec des gens Géraldine est
d'accord aussi c'est bizarre cette place
surtout quand on parle mais et du coup
voilà j'ai cette année je rayure un
sapin chez moi qui sera assez beau assez
grand c'est ça ton secret bah quand même
c'est énorme non
il reste là-bas
alors c'est génial alors Delphine elle
aurait pu dire hier j'ai bu un verre
d'eau bravo Delphine
hier soir j'ai bu un verre d'eau
[Applaudissements]
la magie de Noël
[Rires]
ça va boire Delphine va boire
ah merde
c'est génial